[Music]
you always want to be in the room where
it happens you may recognize that song
the room where it happens that of course
is from the hit musical Hamilton after
conquering audiences in this country the
show has now invaded Britain big time as
Mark Phillips reports from London this
perhaps a little ironic that it's now
the hottest thing on stage there good
morning of all the musicals that have
crossed the Atlantic Hamilton may have
arrived in London with the most baggage
it is after all a show about the
American Revolutionary War which the
British famously lost so how would it
play in the land of the losers easy that
was then this is now
I'm the damn fool that shot him the same
question that had been asked when the
show opened in New York was asked even
louder when it opened in London
[Music]
[Applause]
the once little-known founding father of
the American Revolution was even less
known here not anymore
what had blown away Broadway the punchy
hip-hop beats the rap style lyrics the
white founding fathers played by actors
of color
blew away the cobwebs of stereotype from
London's West End just as quickly
and jamol Westman the hometown actor who
plays
wasn't surprised
we can see today that both American
history and British history is wrapped
up and if you think about current
political climates as it were or world
politics we are very much intertwined in
each other's history the choices that we
make here are the choices that are made
in America will affect every one office
and that seeking exactly massively said
in that respect still could a British
cast accomplice were an American cast
had done in New York Rachel John south
London through and through plays one of
Hamilton's romantic interest Angelica
Schuyler
Giles Tarara also a Londoner to the core
won the Olivier Best Actor in a musical
award for his take on Hamilton's nemesis
Ehrenburg to bring something like that
here and to use the British cast me you
don't talking now you don't sound like
you sound onstage but going into having
a match yeah the acclaim as I say that
that this play had on on Broadway does
that raise the stakes that raised the
pressure yes yes so and as far as you
let it the trick they say is not to let
it the show's success in New York may
have meant its fame preceded it but
there was another dangerous history how
would a musical about an American
victory and the British defeat of the US
war of independence play here if you're
doing historic winners and losers this
is a play about the winners in the place
of the losers the losers the
Wainwright's is not really about Britain
losing it's about it's about that group
of people gaining their independence
being free there is one slight
adjustment in the play here the
character of the British king at the
time George the third is played a bit
more for laps
less perhaps as a villain he's a big hit
and so's the play away my sold out of
course the place may be different but
the themes are universal there's a line
which is a famous line which is
immigrants we get the job done yeah
and that resonates with people in
America and it resonates with audiences
here Britain too has its immigrant story
and the London cast of Hamilton is part
of it
a generation of people and their
children who were brought over to
rebuild the country after the war and
work on buses and working hospitals my
mother was in there yeah and so whether
it's now or let's 250 years ago or 200
years time you kind of think if
someone's that brilliant writing that
will that will speak to different people
in different countries at different
times how good works it works it works
it works
yeah and it works one difference here
for New York is they've managed to keep
ticket scalping prices down only the
person who bought the ticket could use
it and you've got to show picture ID to
get in Nora
what if you're buying a gift for
somebody and it said only the person who
bought the ticket that's okay it's still
a great play however you get to go see I
know don't don't like that little rule
don't like that look don't you want to
see it now and again I know it would be
time number four for me yeah a London
verse but Lindemann moment Miranda says
this is one of the best cast ever
well yep he has seen it and totally
approves I think no matter where you see
Hamilton it's a good door I hear that
these guys are exception the French I
mean the British and the American can
they can join together and making fun of
the French which the play does so that's
one thing that crosses the Atlantic yes
and the King has played for Laughs here
too
yeah in fact it got so whenever the King
walked out on stage you would start
cracking up before he even opened his
mouth because you knew it was gonna be
something so Galerius